γισου να σε κάνουν να ξανασικωστείς να βρίζ αυτή τη επιπρςσετι δύναμην πριν από το
μεταλλειων είχαδος ο πολύ σοαροστραγματισμός το μετάλλιο τυ δόδέκαο ο πρώτος ταν δυσκοκύλι στη μέση
πρώτος γιατρός κουμε διάγνωσε εν επε συνησία που επέ να σταματίσι ότην ιστίο πλογια αντιραμβάνεσε
πολλά μαυρασίι να φα βάνω στο μυάλό του παύλου φυσικά κ των άκουσα αλλάτα γιατρος
μέχι να κούσ αυτό που ήθελά αλλά γάλςδέκα που ήταν ο τραματισμός υπήρχαν μήνες και
φάσεις που στυμχά δεν πόσα να παρπατήσωτε πόςταβαροτε σε κράτσασμα που μόνοςσμο και ακόμα δεν
είχα κάποιαν τόσο μεγάλι επιτυχία που να ξέρεισε ότι ήμονα και μικρός ότι σίγουρα θα
έρθείς πσω θα καταφέρεις να σει στο επιεδο που θέλει θα καταθαπσει στο άθρο να
διεκρικήσεις αυτά που ονιρεύες γιατί τοτέον ιρευόμου και έλεγαστοχόν και έξεραν ιστενήματο επαι ότι προσπαθοία
μεταλλιών ο πλή στος κόσμος το θεωρούσε ότι η μετρελός δεν ίθουστιοπλς τι θα θετες
ναίοισωθενί στας αν και δεν ξέρο να πειζοταίνεις να αθλημα που μάρισί παρα πολύκ και
ανα παρακολουθώ μάριση το ιγονός ότι υπάρχουνται σεις διαφρετικές επιφάνεις που το συγκυρντλίγο μετις διαφετικές
υθήκες παντιμετωπίζουμε εμείς στο μέσα στο νερών μάρεση τη το ιών ότι έχει μεγάλη διαρκιαν
το μάς και μεγάλι διαρκ το τουρνοά κάτι που πάλι έτσι λιγών συν κρινομητή στιοπλία
υτέρα στην αφορά είναι ότι στην στεπλάνει ένα σεναντίον όλον ενώς το θενησίζε ένας εναντίών
ενός στερήθηκες πράγματα μεααυτή τη διάδρομη μεχριάύγε ύοφορές στο βάθον και περιστότερες τε υστεριση ακούς
έτσι σαν κάνε αρνηδικόν όμως έλιψ